salzburg tennengau die unwetter der
letzten tage hinterließen ein bild der
verwüstung die straßenverbindung
zwischen rosbach und abtenau ist durch
die zerstörte neuhaus brücke nicht mehr
passierbar nun hilft das bundesheer bei
der beseitigung der hochwasserschäden im
tennengau unterrichtet eine
behelfsbrücke auf der paß gschütt straße
über einen rußbach wir sind deshalb hier
weil nur das bundesheer das kann aber es
ist immerhin eine eine bundesstraße die
hier weggerissen wurde
das heißt es ist von hoher wichtigkeit
sie in kürzester zeit wieder
herzustellen und das können nur wir das
österreichische bundesheer hat die vier
punkte also mehr klar man habe nach dem
reinigen und die rostocker kamen haben
sie uns noch ab genau aussehe und dafür
einige probleme derzeit ja das ist
perfekt das ist bunt ist ja dass bei uns
los und muss dann wohl zufrieden das
geht schneller
wir hoffen dass wir bald wie möglich
eine verbindung nach woche wieder haben
wir sehen den rosbach mit 62 soldaten
der kompanie des bürgerbataillons trotz
der schwarzenbergkaserne davon ist eine
soldatin dabei wir haben im einsatz
einen großen monitor einen kleinen
monitor einen kompaktlader dass wir in
66 meter damen grant mehrere kippe un
damit haben wir derzeit an das baustelle
66,9 tonnen angeboten wird
also ich bin mit arbeiten des
österreichischen bundesheer sehr sehr
zufrieden
die männer unter der leitung von
hauptmann freynick sind sofort angerückt
haben sofort mit dem brückenbau begonnen
und wir sehen jetzt licht am ende des
tunnels dass man nächsten freitag die
straße wieder befahrbar machen ohne das
bundesheer werden wir hilflos ausgesetzt
gewesen und hätten nur die verbindung
über gehabt